pas comme en championnat le 6 août 1945
la vie s'est arrêtée à hiroshima 75 ans
plus tard l'histoire de la bombe qui a
fait près de 140 mille morts est
racontée dans le roman graphique la
bombe
j'ai l'impression que ce livre l'a fait
en sorte qu'on puisse voir une image
plus large que ce qu'on connaît de la
bombe atomique habituellement le bds le
québécois denis rodier a passé quatre
ans à dessiner ce pavé de 450 planche
ces images en noir et blanc montre la
découverte de l'uranium puis tout le
travail des scientifiques et des
militaires pour fabriquer la bombe
un travail méticuleux et de longue
haleine c'est une discipline de travail
qui avait en sorte que je puisse le
faire
c'est colossal simplement pour chaque
petit détail qu'il faut vérifier comptes
vérifiés
l'histoire se termine avec le
bombardement atomique d'hiroshima où
denis rodier s'est rendu en 2018 en
compagnie des deux co scénariste du
livre en étant sur les lieux ayant accès
au musée de la paix on pouvait à
fouiller dans les archers puis voir des
choses qu'on peut pas nécessairement
trouver sur internet
denis rodier s'est illustrée dans les
années 90 pour son travail chez dc
comics et ses dessins de superman avec
la bombe
c'est avec un scénariste belge est un
scénariste français qu'il a partagé le
travail
il a vraiment donné le meilleur de
lui-même mais franchement il a fourni un
travail incroyable en quatre ans fournir
450 planches d'une telle qualité
je ne sais toujours pas comment comment
il a fait comment c'est possible
le livre la bombe s'est écoulé à 75000
exemplaires il a aussi rapporté cinq
prix ici et à l'international est
véritablement fait la banque pour moi et
j'ai l'impression pour beaucoup de mes
collègues de l'album qui complet donc
d'un point de vue artistique
d'un point de vue historique d'un point
de vue de gagner à sion près d'un an
après la sortie de la bombe de niro dit
n'en revient toujours pas du succès
critique et commercial
jeanne n'arrête pas d'étonner cc c'est
complètement fou parce que après après
toutes ces années de métier il ya des
hauts et des bonnes là bon les astres se
sont alignés
ici louis depuis mai radio canada
montréal
[Musique]